[Music]
hi I'm Hannah your friendly neighborhood
why mom in light of everything that has
happened I want to talk about the worst
things about being a woman first when
you get home at the end of the day and
you see that you've been going around
the entire day with lipstick all over
your teeth I talked to a good 30 people
throughout the day who I thought were my
friends and they failed to tell me and
just made me go on looking like a doofus
the entire day next when you go to put
up your hair and you realize you have no
hair time bonus point if it's a windy
day double bonus if you're wearing lip
gloss O'Hara next the wage gap next
periods they stuck everybody knows this
this is like the most commonly known
fact but I just have to bring light to
it because oh my god why does your body
punish you for not being pregnant it
should be a reward yes underwear I don't
know who formulates the patterns for
underwear but like thongs stuck cool
finds comfort in pulling something up
there pop but if I wear something that's
a little more comfortable and loose it
has more coverage all of a sudden it's
called granny panties you can never win
next when you have a chain necklace and
it gets a knot I've spent like 45
minutes trying to get a knot out you
have to like mushroom around they get
loose and then try to pick them apart
it's almost like surgery
I pay my little sister who has tinier
fingers to do it for me
next straight white men wanting to
control your uterus next when your
period comes it's always at a very
inconvenient time I'll be like waiting
and waiting and waiting like come on
period I know you're coming and it's not
until I'm in the middle of a big
presentation in front of a roomful of
people and I'm like now look at this
next taking a tampon to the bathroom I
don't know who designed the packaging of
these tampons but it's like [ __ ]
Christmas morning anytime you try to
take a tampon out of your purse next
we're not able to stand up in pee we
went camping last weekend and it was
dark and the bathrooms were disgusting
and it was cold and I had to pee
squatting in the bushes and I don't know
if I'm doing it wrong but the pee gets
all over you next having to pay for
birth control
next childbirth we did a whole video on
that go watch it next walking alone at
night I walk with my keys between my
fingers my mom
has sent me an alarm to attach to my
keys in case I'm in trouble
that's how concerned she is for me
walking alone in the dark that's the sad
reality of our society is that women do
not feel safe doing something as simple
as walking down the street last dresses
with no pockets that's like awkward
today I'm Hannah your friendly
neighborhood why mom if there's anything
I missed in this video leave it in the
comments and as always if there's
anything you want me to talk about in a
future episode leave that in the
comments as well and I know I talked
about the worst parts of being a woman
but the best part about being a woman is
all of you guys who watch this series I
love all the women who watch this and
all the men and I love you guys and
together we're strong together we're
amazing so next time
[Music]
you
[Music]